pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la bombe qui a explosé à anan capitale
de la jordanie et qui a causé la mort de
11 personnes parmi lesquelles le premier
ministre raza elle match ali a rallumé
brutalement les querelles du proche
orient
il est significatif que le roi hussein
qui a échappé de justesse à l'attentât
et mis en cause la convoitise de son
puissant voisin la république arabe unie
[Musique]
europe afrique noire relations est ouest
autant de sujets que le général de
gaulle devait évoquer au cours de sa
conférence de presse en même temps que
celui de l'algérie vis-à-vis de laquelle
il a tenu à préciser sa pensée il ya une
injure il ya une entité algérienne ya
une personnalité algérienne
c'est aux algériens qu'il appartient de
décider de leur destin
il y a neuf millions environ d'habitants
en algérie bref s'il y en a un peu plus
d'un million qui sont de souche
française est aussi nombre de musulmans
qui ne veut pas être séparé de la france
en hockey accord et jean d'un drop
vivent en algérie puisque c'est leur
terre natale
il ya dans la métropole quatre cent
mille algériens qui travaillent c'est à
dire le cinquième de la population
masculine active de l'algérie les
travailleurs actifs masculin et parce
qu'ils y viennent dans la métropole ils
font vivre leurs familles qui sont
généralement de l'autre côté de la mer
et qui compte plus de 2 millions de
personnes en cas de rupture environ t-il
au caire à tunis à rabat à pékin et
moscou à new york
et puis enfin faut-il ou non que
l'algérie se transforme en un pays
moderne et prospère
si oui quelle est la puissance qu'ils
puissent s'y prêtait concourir dans des
proportions et dans les conditions
voulues où seule la france et le général
conclut en évoquant à la fois l'avenir
de la france et celui de son propre rôle
pour ce qui est de la france ce qui est
capital c'est que par le temps qui court
elle garde sa cohésion nationale et de
tout mon coeur
je me félicite de constater qu'il en est
ainsi de temps en temps à me dit où on
me fait dire bah oui vous êtes là ce
soir gentil à mon égard et par
conséquent bien ne après jour ce sera la
pagaille alors quelques-uns suggère que
l'on institut la pagaille tout de suite
le mannois assurer la succession ou bien
je demande à réfléchir construire sur le
zambèze à barrage capable de rivaliser
avec les chutes victoria est une tâche
qui ne va pas sans complication pour peu
qu'on ait le coeur sensible et c'est le
cas de tout anglais digne de ce nom
dès qu'il s'agit des bêtes petit ou
grand
ainsi at-on été amenés à administrer un
anesthésique à madame rhinocéros étant
donné la masse à endormir
on comprendra que les faits étaient est
long à se manifester
[Musique]
enfin la bête fut réduite au calme et
ferme non un arrêt sur un brancard ont
pu embarquer sur un radeau il convient
ici de préciser le but de l'entreprise
éviter à l'animal de se retrouver isolée
au milieu du lac artificiel et de périr
noyé la rive atteinte
l'opération rhinocéros arrivait à son
terme mais restait une inconnue
l'effet de l'anesthésique serait il
tuera on vit bien que non et la fureur
de l'animal se tourne à un continent
contre ces sauveurs quand il est vrai
que la reconnaissance et un sentiment
bien mal partagée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
première des nombreuses surprises des
jeux de rome le champion olympique
américain aubry yen sera battu par son
compatriote ni d'air qui bien qu'ayant
failli ne pas être sélectionné lancera
le poids à 19 m 68 record olympique
battue et trois américains dans les
premiers le 100 m plat sera une dure
épreuve pour la réputation des
sprinteurs des états unis
elle m'en a ri coiffe à l'arrivée
l'américain dave sim 10 secondes 2/10
record olympique égal
dans le saut en hauteur pas d'espoir
pour les français fournier et idriss
fournier ne dépassera pas 2 m 3
idriss lui échoit à 2 m 6
sensation le grand favori l'américain
thomas recordwoman du monde avec deux
mètres 23 ne dépassera pas 2 mètres 14
et laissera la médaille d'or aux ruches
à flat 4 et 2 m 16 record olympique
battue à la piscine olympique le
programme n'avait pas indiqué à la
princesse de monaco et le français
christophe dans le 100 m dos malgré une
belle performance ne serait que 4e
l'australien t-il en une minute
une seconde 9/10 et l'américain mckinley
en une minute deux secondes trois
dixièmes remporté les médailles d'or et
d'argent
au tremplin le mexique a bottle annales
gré un très bon quadruples sauts
périlleux ne sera que troisième
[Musique]
devant lui l'américain aux l'enlèvera la
médaille d'argent et c'est avec la
précision presque mécanique qui
caractérise son style que tu obtiens
donnera également aux états unis la
médaille d'or
[Musique]
par contre on vole les espoirs des
plongeuses américaine ne tiendront pas
devant les performances de l'allemande
kramer celle ci aura d'ailleurs réussi à
vendre un remarquable doublé olympique
tremplin et orale
à la finale du 100 mètres dos féminin la
favorite burke états unis dire la
première talonné par l'anglais stewarts
dès la sortie du virage elle dominera
largement et terminera avec une longueur
d'avancé tandis que la française pierre
santini ligne numéro 1 tout en égalant
le temps de la troisième
manquera de justesse la médaille de
bronze cependant sur le lac d'albano la
france avait remporté en aviron sa
première médaille d'argent
leucate français avec barreur remontait
en effet magnifiquement ses adversaires
italiens puis russe est terminé à 2
secondes de l'équipe allemande médaille
d'or au saut en longueur
boston avec un bond de 8 mètres 12
record olympique donner la médaille d'or
aux usa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
finale à sensation enfin le 200 m plat
le public attendait la confiance du
favori l'italien berruti et du français
abdou sèye
celui ci avec son habituelle des parts
rolland se trouvait en cinquième
position dans la ligne droite
[Musique]
mais après le virage remarquablement
pris par des routiers et l'américain
carnet cei numéro 465 faisaient une
sensationnelle remonter le statut et
innovation inoubliable aux 3 and said va
secondes 7/10 carnet 20 secondes 6/10
des routes y vas seconde 5/10 record du
monde et galets record olympique battue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]